okay um welcome
welcome to the gdpr seminar everyone
let's go over some logistics first
please mute yourself during the talk
unless you have questions if you have
questions you are welcome to mute and
ask
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them in q a
sessions
second ddps
seminar is open to external audiences
therefore no classified discussion is
allowed and finally the talk today will
be recorded and uploaded in our youtube
channel
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today
actually let me get rid of the
okay let me introduce our speaker today
um it is an honor to host dimitri and
his travel
and any straw uh 12
who is a professor of nuclear
engineering engineering at north
carolina carolina state university
he works in the field of computational
physics numerical analysis and particle
transport theory
his research involves development of
iteration methods for the boltzmann
transport equation
computational methods for multiphysics
and multi-scale problems
mathematical models of particle
transport in various physical systems
reduce total models
prior to joining nc state he was a
research staff member of
caldish institute for applied
mathematics
and institute for mathematical modeling
of russian
academy of sciences
visiting assistant professor at the
department of new
nuclear engineering at texas a m
university
dimitri
had served as a guest scientist to the
computational transport group at los
alamos
national laboratory he is currently a
guest scientist
at the center of applied scientific
computing at lawrence livermore national
lab
as a matter of fact
he's on site so if you want to
have a discussion with dmitry please
feel free to email him and
maybe you guys can see uh on site
and discuss
and dimitri uh received his phd in
mathematical and physical sciences from
russian academy of sciences and ms
degree
in physics from moscow institute of
physics and technology
today dimitri will present an
interesting topic which is reduced
models for thermal radiative transfer
problems
based on moment equations and pod dmd of
eddington tensor
please enjoy and expect a wonderful talk
now without further ado let me pass the
button
by asking one random questions as usual
since it is friday today today's random
question is
what are your favorite things to do
during the weekend dimitri
traveling
around california
oh yes
yes yeah you're taking advantage of
being here right that's it definitely
yeah all right it's all yours
okay thank you very much for
introduction and of course thank you
very much for
for invitation this is a very nice
opportunity to present to
this audience so this is the title of
the talk i will talk about reduced
automotives for
thermal radiative transfer based on
moment equations and pod and dmd
weddington factor a tensor
so a short outline of my talk uh i will
briefly introduce basic ideas and of
course i will start defining
what kind of problems we consider
uh then i will derive multi-level uh
lower the quasi-diffusion equations for
the boltzmann transport equation these
type of equations are also known as
variable eddington factor equations
uh then they formulate uh data driven
reduced total models for for this type
of problems using pod and dmd over the
condenser present numerical some
numerical results uh into the
cartesian geometry finish with
discussion and of course i want to
attract attention uh announced that this
is my joint work with uh
joacol who is my grad student at north
carolina state university
so um
this is all about simulation of particle
transport phenomena and
there are several significant challenges
to that type of physical problem first
of all higher dimensionality and that's
why we talk here about reduced other
models
but it's also multiple scales uh strong
non-linearity
and uh strong coupling
between equations so for example in
thermal radiative transfer opacities
depend on state of matter and state of
matter
is significantly affected by
fluxes of photons in this case and other
particles
then system of equation usually has
different types of equations involved in
it
then there is different characteristic
behavior
from various viewpoints in different
energy ranges
and
another important thing about boltzmann
transport equation that it is integral
differential
equation and differential appearance is
hyperbolic but integral one
couples everything in every point
of the domain
so those are major challenges so now um
about thermal radiated
transfer problem uh so it is defined by
the uh
boltzmann transport equation oh well
it's also called radiative transfer
equation so this is multi-group uh so
the solution is intensity high it's the
intensity specific intensity of four
ones g index group index so i is
actually integral over certain range of
uh
frequency interval chosen for a given
problem uh x position omega
direction of uh photon travel
uh nts time of course
um so it's multi-dimensional
uh
boundary condition initial conditions as
shown here uh boundary condition
specified for incoming directions in the
domain g
then in that
fundamental charity problem
the boltzmann transfer equation is
coupled with material energy balance
equation so epsilon is energy that
usually non-linearly non-linear
dependent on temperature t is
temperature capitalist temperature
coppers are opacities
or sometimes cross-sections uh b sub g
is the plankton
function so that describes
describes um
emission the spectrum of emission in
in equilibrium in this case local
equilibrium so and this is really a
fundamental thermally related traffic
model so
it neglects heat conduction scattering
external sources as well as material
motion
and it models for example supersonic
radiation wave now
uh
the reason we consider this problem
and and try to develop methods for that
particular problem because it's actually
a very good available test platform for
uh
development method for general radiated
transfer problems like radiative
hydrodynamics
so there are important um
applications for trt first of all high
energy density physics inertial
confinement fusion uh in astrophysics of
course
uh and some others and as you noticed uh
there are some
important similarities with with the
general problems like radiative
hydrodynamics it's high dimensionality
non-linearity
different scales in time and space and
energy
strong coupling between
boltzmann transport equation and
material energy balance equation and
different behaviors in different energy
ranges
so now about dimensionality so let's do
little little arithmetics so we look at
intensity that is
one of our primary unknowns and compare
with temperature which is
very good representation of what we
usually
have before
state of matter so state of meta depends
only on space and time
and intensity depends also on directions
and energy
on frequency group or
combo frequency groups
so and if we just look at the number of
variables in three d k so we have seven
independent variables and uh
we start looking at very harsh mesh in
space for example we have hundred
hundred by hundred so we get ten
to six
uh cells in this case hundred directions
hundred groups hundred times moment uh
instances of time that we want to look
at
in problem uh we will get 10 to 12
unknowns and we look about for example
10 flock per unknown we get
0.1 petaflop in this case so that's why
we always want uh to
find some good reduced order models and
there are very famous ones like
diffusion equation p1 equation ospn
equation so and of course we but they
have quite uh limitations for in terms
of accuracy and in terms of convergence
if you wish to the exact solution
so um now about the main elements of
the presented methodology that i'm going
to show so first of all it's non-linear
projection approach and you can look at
this at the result of applications
approach in many different ways first of
all uh you can look at this as method of
moments because the equation will be
written for moments of the intensity uh
you can look at this as multi-level
method because we will define a
hierarchy of equations
and it can be viewed as a multi-grid
method because it's basically
has
different grids in the face space
this method introduces some average
quantities that are essential for
closing this euro q equation so that's
why there are elements of homogenization
method and
when we define this multi-level system
of question hierarchy we actually
sequentially reduce dimensionality so
that's why this projection approach of
course it's a method for reduction of
dimensionality
and it's perfect in this regard with all
those properties for solving
for applying to multiphysics multiscale
problems
developing approximate models
reduced order models and
as a result you can use it for there is
the resulting equations and reduced to
the models for sensitivity and certainty
analysis
now in terms of data compression
techniques we will apply them to
closures
that we use for this multi-level
equations and we will use
proper orthogonal decomposition and
dynamic mode decomposition for these
closures specifically adding contents
now a very short overview of general
approach or this non-linear projection
approach
if we have some equation
l psi s psi equals epsilon plus q where
l and s some given operators with some
different properties and in this case we
can think that l is differential
operator and s is integral operator so
it's kind of
the structure of uh boltzmann equation
uh then psi is function of
quite a number of independent variables
so we introduce couple of projection
operators p for the equations and we
project the equation and then we need we
have in mind uh close this system of
equations so that's why we need another
operator f
that will then give us projection for uh
or
the solution itself to to define
new uh set of functions that we will
consider unknowns
with uh we will we may have more fun
more known functions but they will
depend on fewer independent
variables and this is the basis for this
year
multi-year euro q equations
so then uh we take this
projective equations and close them
equivalently with some
functionals or factors
and get
lower the equations projected equations
for now for new set of unknowns size
uh and this load operator now depends
nonlinearly on uh functions that were
introduced
the next step in
finishing a formulation is we need to
have prolongation operator that will
connect
our unknowns in projected space with the
original space so we introduced some
prolongation operator m that also can
depend on some functions of factors and
as a result we get a system of higher
order problem
modified so where the right hand side of
this equation is modified with a
projection operator m enclosed with some
functionals and load the problem
defined for new unknowns it's a
non-linear operator and our exact
closures are gammas and betas
so now uh i will walk you through uh
derivation of
system of equations for uh boltzmann
equation the radiative transfer equation
so-called quasi-diffusion equations
they're also known as variable directing
factor and the reason they're called
quasi-diffusion because they
will remind you
diffusion but they are not diffusion
they're exact equations because the
closures are exact
so we take first uh angular moments
or moments in terms of omega with one
and uh with omega
so this gives us
and we
picked up the set of unknowns natural
for this type of problem so usually this
class of problems are interested in
energy density e
uh and f
or flux
so that's why just just applying these
moments we get two unclosed
equations actually this is the vector
equation so in general three equations
and this is the highest moment h
which is basically a tensor omega omega
i
and what is done here is that
this moment is
is closed
with
eddington or quasi diffusion tensor
which can be interpreted as basically
average omega omega
where intensity is the averaging
function and what's nice about this
uh is that these functional are stable
and that's what i kind of missed uh on
the previous couple of slides that the
closures uh the idea for this nonlinear
projection is to close
your new system of equations with some
factors and functions that are stable
to uh variation of of of the higher
order solution then it gives some
stability in terms of iterations when
you start solving this non-linear system
equation so as a result
we get a closed system of equations of
zeros and first moments
defined for uh group energy density and
radiation incidentally and group flux
so the next step is to take these uh
moment equations closed moment equations
and
basically average them over energy or
with some over energy
groups or frequency groups i will
probably keep going back and forth
because energy and frequency in this
case
uh are related uh photon energy so um in
this case unknowns are total
radiation energy density which is a
summation
over all groups of eg and total flux
again
when we sum those equations we get
some terms that are not closed for
example this term of kind of absorption
term
in
the first moment equation and
another absorption term as another terms
here
um
in the second equation and we'll
introduce uh average
grade effective gray
eddington tensor
where this will be averaged with eg
we introduce
gray
opacities
and
here we introduce some effective
gray opacities that average with
different function
actually
so it will be a tensor
diagonal tensor
which is averaged with
another function so actually absolute
value of f
and as a result we get
now
closed system equations for now total
energy
radiation energy density and total flux
and let me show now on this slide
uh the whole system of equation
hierarchy
so we have high order
boltzmann transport equation
and
that
where opacities and the right-hand side
emission term depends on temperature
multi-group load across the diffusion
equation for uh radiation energy density
and
group
group energy densities and and fluxes
then
so the
to
group
group eddington tensor
formulates the closure so that's why we
can solve transport equation
get intensities
get closures at intent tensor
define this multi-group lower degrees of
diffusion equation the solution of this
equation define closures for effective
gray equations
there was a moment equation and
the material energy balance equation is
coupled at that level
now
so and of course it's transformed with
similar effective great quantities
so now it's the
uh the system of equations non-linear
system equation that is equivalent to
original one
and it seems like we got more equations
that than before and it seems like we
were supposed to do more work
than before because we have more
equation but it's actually
uh opposite because the way this system
requestion is formulated allows you to
solve this
original trt problem
quite effectively the iteration process
that goes through the whole system
equation converges extremely fast
and it it gives you effectiveness in
that regard so there are a lot of
details but this is uh this is not the
point of this work uh the point of this
work that if you have this system
equation now you can
consider that what if you have data
for the eddington tensor
group heading condenser so then you can
do various approximation with data
compression techniques and then you get
approximate closures of various
qualities
for this moment's system system of
moment equations
so that's that's the idea of of this
work is that now
uh
we generate data for
eddington tensor so then we can use a
full full model for example order model
or from some experimental data so we can
use for example pod or dmd or reddington
tensor and that will get cl closures of
different
quality in terms of
approximation and then
the system movement system
coupled with real energy balance
equation can be solved and
and give us a reduced order model
so now um
i will
mention how we discretize this equation
when we move to
uh numerical results but
in any case when you discretize this
system of equations you eventually have
some spatial cells and i will consider
simplicity that cells are orthogonal and
rectangular octagonal and now we will
look at what we need to do in terms of
generating
data for
data compression techniques
and let's let's assume that we have that
kind of cell
and that we approximate equations in a
way that
this moment equations require certain
grids uh grid
functions of uh
paddington tensor components of element
and sensor so first of all this is with
with
subscript c mean that it's cell average
components of the tensor
then of course usually phase
quantities are involved so we will need
phase average quantities of adding and
tensor by the way not all components
that's kind of the result of
discretization of moment equation so we
have some set of grids functions of four
components of addington sensor that we
need
we can generate them from uh for example
full order model a specific one that
that we're interested in to then
simulate and consider how good
various approximations
so
then we can generate snapshot
snapshots of
components of tensor interface space
over the whole
range of uh energy and and and or in all
groups
and over the whole spatial domain so
this vector represents alpha and beta at
some tensor
components uh but it's the whole
set of data for that component of of
grid's function
for in all groups
in all space in the whole spatial domain
over the whole range of time that we're
interested in
then we generate uh data matrices and in
this case we have the data
to uh perform some approximation using
for example pod or dmd
that's what is done in this work
so just
to remind you uh
the idea of proper technology
composition how we use it here so we
have data matrix now of snapshots of
components of grid's function of
addington tensor
those grids functions that we need for
our discretized load across diffusion
equations
we can perform a singular value
decomposition that will give us as a
product of
left singular vectors
diagonal matrix of singular
singular
values
and
these v is
matrix of
right singular vectors so then uh it
gives us certain
rank d it's the maximum rank that is
defined by uh by
number of singular values and then we
can use lower rank approximation of uh
adding 10 components of addington tensor
or grid functions
using low rank approximation of a in
this case and as a result we have this
expansion where u small and v are
corresponding
uh singular vectors
now uh if we use or when we use a dmd
so dmd uh
looks at the data and tries to find a
best
linear operator that represents
evolution of this time dependent that or
dynamics so that's why basically we get
a dynamic system for components of
edinton tensor
and if we
have this
matrix b linear operator then we can
solve this and this is the typical
representation of this linear
uh or the e system over these and that's
what uh to to do dmd so we
according to classical russian we
use uh constant time step form uh two
sets of data matrices which are sifted
shifted data matrices so the first one
is from the first time step two
and t minus one to
first to to to last
and then from second to the last uh
instant of time that we're interested in
the cover
and
then dmd
generates the closest approximation of
being fibrinous norm which is
uh product of
x
hat this matrix and x plus which is uh
pseudo inverse of of matrix x
so then we get representation of
our
vector f
as as this
this expansion
in eigenfunction and
frequencies that we get from analysis of
this matrix actually as
uh feeds who is a
vectors eigenvectors of b tilde
and that's that's the first version uh
another one that we can also
use equilibrium subtracted md and that's
what we do here so basically then we
operate not with the original data but
with the data where we subtracted from
each
uh vector the equilibrium
or some uh some vector that we consider
useful for
[Music]
considering then the difference between
data and some instant of time that is
interesting and usually for example if
you solve time dependent uh trt problem
there is uh it determines to steady
state problem of course provided that
the source is constant in time and in
incoming but conditions are constant
time so in our case this equilibrium
value is actually the last instant of
time which is really close to steady
state
so now uh some test problems to show how
things work so this is a 2d
version of very famous flat comment test
that was published long time ago in jcp
this test
provides you with
spectral opacities as a function of new
and and temperature
uh it has linear energy density material
energy density
and
there is incoming radiation at the left
boundary
for uh with
with planking spectrum at temperature
one kv
and initial condition for temperature in
the whole domain and one ev or ten to
minus 3
kv
it's a square domain from
0 to 6 in both direction and vacuum
boundary condition top bottom and
right
so we can see the interval of time
from 0 to 69 seconds and we use time
step 2 10 to minus 200 seconds
so it's basically total 300 time steps
we form
17 groups that i adjusted for that
particular time problem group structure
so 17g
17 we use 20 by 20 uh
uniform our terminal grid now we have an
axis
400 we use uh quadruple
quadrature
with 36
angles per octane so total we get 144
directions and in terms of
discretization of multi-level system of
equations for
boltzmann transfer the question we use
fully implicit in time and simple uh
corner balance in space
we use discrete ordinance
for
the rest of the system will also use
fully implicit in time and and in space
multi-group law requires diffusion
equations are discretized with second or
the finite volume scheme that's where
the specific
uh
the specifics of grid's function for
addington tensor
come from it it tells you where you need
to generate when you need to define
those uh grid functions and effective
grail or the quads diffusions are
derived
by algebraic consistent discretization
of multi with multi-group load across
diffusion equations
so now let's take a look a little bit at
numbers so in this
case we have
300 time steps
and we have
cells
144 directions in angle
and 17 groups so it gives us about 10 to
unknowns and it's just a kind of
orientation in terms of because some
unknowns we have a little bit more of
them so this is about 10 to 6 and
when we look at just load
equations so the dimensionality of this
problem is significantly less so it's
about six
seven ten times one to three and we have
the same number of timestamps and this
is just a little uh illustration of how
the wave propagates and actually this is
not 20 by 20 cells it's just 10 by 10
for this movie
and now uh let's look at results so
first we start from analysis of
addington tensor
and we use
these criterion for determining rank
for the approximation that we would like
to use we look at
the ratio between
between singular values square score
singular values
truncated those that from
desired rank r to the full rank
and compare that with all uh ranges of
of singular values so basically it tells
you
what is the fraction of energy uh in
modes of of an angular
singular vector mode
that we neglect
and
psi is the criterion so and this is the
graph
for
the case we look at pod expansion of
eddington tensor and all those curves
are for different grids functional for
different components of eddington tensor
and this is the criterion 10 to minus 2
10 to minus 4 and this is the rank
maximum rank is 300 so if we pick up the
lowest rank uh oh 10 to -2 so the rank
will be about
uh 15
if we go to 10 to minus 4 it will be
about 40. and now compare
this with the full phase space
where
the intensity leaves so and so and
further so of course the the the titanic
criterion the higher rank
uh this is the same for dmd
uh dmd has a little bit
lower rank actually for each absolute
but this actually results with uh to a
little bit
less accurate approximation disregard i
don't show here dmd uh with equilibrium
subtraction because it's very similar
it's actually very similar to uh to
pod in this case
so the analysis shows that we can so
this that
up to ten to minus six which would be
very nice in terms of quality of
approximation it's it goes up to just 15
so it's a
nice so it's mean that we really have
some good compression in this regard so
now the results uh first results for
reduced order model based on moment
equations purity of uh eddington tensor
so again this is the same criterion i
just remind you that we solve it with
this time step two ten to minus two
nanoseconds over the range from zero to
six nanoseconds and those graphs shows
the relative error in two norm
for temperature
uh produced by reduced automotives for
various criterions of xci
compared to full order model forward
model is the one that was solved on that
at particular given phase space grid and
time
but that exact method with uh with
solving time-dependent boltzmann
equation approximated with simple code
and balance so that's why this is our
full order model and we want to see how
we actually
approximate the equation that we
generated and
uh
the first line so here it's for
psi ten to minus two and the error over
the full range of
of time that way it's about ten to minus
four if we increase
uh
we make it title for a couple of what is
a magnet 10 to minus 4.
the error goes to 10 to minus 6.
then extra order two orders of magnet
shows 10 to minus
8. so basically it's about two orders of
magnitude times
psi
in this regard and
we see that we
rather uniformly converge so we can say
that's kind of uniformly converge
in in
with with psi and that's what we want to
make sure that it goes back to
basically truncation of our
numerical error from uh translation
error
numerical calculation so that when we
take full range 10 to minus 16 we'll
give you a for that we would get back to
the
quality of the solution that we got
because the convergence criterion was
about 10 to minus
15 actually there so the same is for
energy density so you can see it's very
similar in terms of
the
error that we get uh now the same
results for dmd
and i mentioned that uh
the rank for the same uh
psi
like 10 to minus 2 for example is a
little bit less and that's just
reflected in terms of the
the error in uh
two norm compared to full order models
so the error is about 10 to minus 2 to
it as of magnitude
greater which is basically its tracks it
tracks
psi but what you also
see with dmd is that as we get closer
and closer to
a very sort of getting using full rank
we started kind of uh getting noise and
we looked at this and we believe that
it's really numerics that prevents us
from getting
to
their original uh quality
and it's sensitive and it's it's known
that dmd is sensitive to some numerics
and especially with low rank
approximation that we use
dmd
uh now this is an equilibrium subtracted
so the equilibrium subtracted shows
improvement in terms of accuracy
for
low rank
and that's what you can see like 10 to
minus 2 gets back to 10 to minus 4 both
for temperature and energy density but
again uh
equilibrium subtracted get
uses more uh
more elements of singular values in this
case higher rank so which is comparable
with pod and that's again that kind of
explains that it gives us a better
accuracy here and
uh it is far more sensitive as we can
see when we go with higher rank
to numerics that
we use for generating
these
vectors and singular values so
now
we
would like to look at how actually we
converge with uh
making this
tolerance
titan tied xi
and what and those curves now show
different instances of time
for different solutions with different
criterions
side
so and so this is almost the very
beginning it's
ten to minus two nanoseconds
so then the rest moments one minute
seconds two three four and six we can
see that basically we have and we looked
at this those are logarithmic
scales so this is psi and this is the
relative
error into norm for for epsilon
so and we see that we converge linearly
here both for energy density and
temperature
so similar behavior for dmd but again
you saw some
numeric some noise
in for a higher rank and that one of
course we'll see that there is some
situation and errors
do not get uh so
stop
converging
into these numerics and uh the behavior
of dmd uh
subtracted singular now those are
integral norms and it's interesting of
course to show
what is the spatial distribution of
errors in this case and this is just one
one instant just for reduced of the
model of pod
just to show that it's a relatively
uniform distribution of errors there is
no some surprises that we missed looking
at
integral norms this is the instant uh
two nanoseconds and those are solutions
actually the temperature for for the
model energy and you can see the
distribution of temperature so this from
one kv up to
about 0.4 on the other side
and this is the shape of
total energy radiation energy density
and those are errors for
the case size ten to minus four
and this is the range between ten to
minus four and ten to minus six relative
uh error in in temperature
and energy uh in energy density
and
this is the increasing error
uh
between this
over this space and this is associated
with the location of the uh
the asian front so that's why kind of a
show so you can see that this is
where the front behaves and that's where
the air
is increased relatively here for that
instant of time but it's relatively
uniform
and now the last set of numerical
results
in a lot of experiments
physicists measure breakout time and
it's very interesting to look at
qualities of these reduced automotives
when we looked actually what happens how
the dynamics of temperature and energy
radiation energy density on the opposite
side of this domain so basically where
the wave comes to
and we looked at average temperature on
the right side
of the domain and energy density on the
right side and this shows how
temperature changes in kv in this case
uh
versus time in this problem from zero to
six nanoseconds
and this is the dynamics of changing
temperature on that side so and that's
basically
shows you that after about three nano
actually about four and a second we've
got very close to steady state it's
still it's changing but it's it's very
very slow process that case so this is
the dynamics of energy density on
on the right side an outgoing phase
so
if you pick up a breakaway time that for
example you are interested in reaching
temperature
of about like for example eighty percent
of uh steady state so it could be so you
can pick up any instant and we look just
at all instances to see what how uh
things happen how those models
approximate
breakout
for
measurements and those are errors from
three different models with uh blue is
pure d
and this is all for 10 to minus four
which is relative small rank rank about
40 for heading 10 tensors
this is pure the error so it's less than
10 to minus 6 for temperature on either
side dynamically again versus time
and energy density on the other side
also blue
then
yellow is
dmd
equilibrium subtracted
also not not very far from pod and a
little bit higher for that case just dmd
but again the indeed
uses a lower rank in that case
so
it shows that this model is quite
accurate especially for practical
calculation because 10 to -6
body of magnitude
so and this is uh so this is conclusion
for my talk
uh so i just want to remind you that
main elements of of proposed
methodologies of non-linear projection
or boltzmann transport equation and
formulation of a multi-level system of
low order equations for moments of
intensity of radiation and
application of data compression
techniques for
approximative closures in this case uh
eddington tensor and this is quite
general approach that can be used for a
quite different class of multiphysics uh
problems especially high energy density
physics
such as
for example radiative hydrodynamics and
we so here we
showed
data compression techniques for
generation closure the eddington tensor
but we also have developed reduced order
modes where we use pod galerkit method
for a boltzmann transfer equation and
that's this uh
method is this pod galorkin projected a
transport equation is used
coupled with
this euro q equations and it also showed
good results and i i will
show you some publications i'll give you
some references so in terms of close
steps in future research of that
particular things of course the optimal
sampling techniques are important to
generate beta data for uh or models to
further improve
efficiency and accuracy of those models
and of course the interesting thing is
parameterized reduced automotives
because you want to have a range of your
parameters
incoming temperatures opacities to
really generate some reduced order
models to perform some
sensitivity analysis or do some fast
design and calculations
and of course i want to acknowledge at
the end a very important item is that
this research has been supported by
department of defense specifically
defense threat reducing agency
and this is a short list of some
publications that we have with jaw on a
related subject
for that reduced auto models
and
please
welcome any questions that you would
like to
thank thank you so much for the great
talk dimitri i like to talk a lot um i
mean trt is
very difficult problem to solve it has
um
all kinds of challenges uh in one
problem like high dimensionality
uh multi-physics and the multi-scales
and um
and
yeah i mean it's yeah it's a large scale
problem in nature so
you are solving a typical problem so
let's have thank you so much for the
great talk and very interesting uh let's
have a q a session
um well initially tom uh raised the
question but he
you answered his question so um i guess
um
[Music]
let's move on to another question um i
don't see any other question in uh in
the chat room
but
i can start with my questions while you
guys are thinking about your um
your questions um
okay so um all these uh the results you
have shown is are they the reproductive
case i i assume so you have it uh the
solution of the full of the model and
then you you just
try to reproduce that uh using the
reviews reduced to the model either pod
or dmd right yes yeah correct
yeah okay so
can you comment on how you would um
extend that to a parametric case because
um that's where
the
model is you know
sure and we actually played with this uh
we played with this in 1d and uh the
publication that is shown here actually
that we did in 2019 when we just uh try
to get
uh idea whether it's a workable approach
so what what uh what we tried uh as as
as the first approach is that we can
generate
uh
this data
for different for example we played with
incoming with temperature of incoming
radiation
and we would generate data
for
several
several different temperatures of
incoming radiation and then basically
when we solve problem we would
interpolate
between
those uh temperatures
for example we defined one kav
and 0.9 kv and then we want to solve
with 0.95 kv so basically we then
interpolate between those
data points uh in this regard we also
and
it showed a
promise in terms of that
you do get reasonable results from a
practical viewpoint of calculations
then we also played in that regard with
actually looking at how good we can
solve the problem with different time
step because another restriction if you
wish and that's what you saw in terms of
this analysis is actually we used the
same time step when we solved uh reduced
automotives but in this 1d version
we
played with solving a problem with
various time steps and again it involves
interpolation
between the data that we have
and that's why we
and that that was uh
[Music]
good we got good results with pod
we tried recently
to look at what we can do with dmd
which dmd looked
quite
promising because it gives you a natural
interpolation function a continuous
function in time
and we
didn't get so far
promising results so
when we start solving a problem with
uh different time steps so that's why
this is this is a puzzle but pod allows
us to this so that's why one of possible
approaches for example of pod is really
generating tables
generating data
for various parameters
and then
looking at the way of interpolating and
of course
a very important factor of
going in that direction is that really
the good sampling for each of data
because the quality of data will be
important and so that we can
even further so and that's what we got
to a certain extent with projected
purity we use different
actually bases for different time ranges
but again that's uh one of the ways to
short answer to your question is that uh
looking at interpolation between data
that you generated for parameters data
uh
reasonably close so it means that you
create a mesh in your parametric space
and that and then
use interpolation and see how how they
behave that's one way
yeah okay that's great um
okay um i don't see any question from
chatroom but don't
don't hesitate you know on with yourself
ask questions uh if you have any um
my my second question is regarding the
speed up because i mean another you know
important aspect of the model is you
know obtaining a speed up that's that's
the whole point of introducing the
radius to the models
um but i haven't seen any results about
the speed of you
in in your so this speed up uh so the
important thing here is
let's return back to
so this is
the whole system of equations uh if you
solve
the transfer equation
or you sold trt problem
right transparent away
so
that's what you will need to solve you
will need to solve high order problem
you will need to sort of lower the
problems and the various methods that
approach
trt uh introduces various
lower the problem not necessarily for
the solution for a residue for uh for
errors
iterative errors etc so and the main
burden here is actually the transport
equation
so by many reasons first of all by
dimensionality
so
that's
what what is done in that reduced order
model is the transfer of equation is
removed from calculations
so that's your saving so they call so
the uh the
effort that you need to
use to solve this type of reduced
automotives is very close to if you use
p1 equations or diffusion
so that's your comparison so basically
we got red so the models with uh
significant with controlled quality
of course
with the available data
for the for the
posts
close to
do p1 equations
multi-group p1 equations and by the way
what i didn't notice that i didn't
mention is that
to get an idea that one equation or
diffusion equation or flux limited
diffusion
will give you errors in these problems
about 10 to minus
relative error
so that's that's the savings that you
get in this case uh another stage
another possible direction
is actually now to apply a reduced uh
some reduction of dimensionality with
that type of approach uh to actually
load their equations that will be the
next stage then
okay
sounds good thank you so much
um is there any other questions from the
audiences
[Music]
no um no questions from the transport
teams here
no
all right great uh
thank you so much dimitri
for the great talk
applause
very nice talk and
i would like to have a
another meeting
with you so that we can discuss further
on the reduced water
but other than that it was it was
awesome okay thank you so much
thank you very much thank you for them
bye yeah thank you everyone uh for your
attendance and uh we will conclude the
seminar today
bye bye